no more g-strings no more stripping so
you want to act david you are also an
amazing host
he did the uh a couple no you are i've
i've called you you hosted the
nickelodeon the team was it the teen
show what's your name yeah the teen
choice awards you're really good on
camera do you have any aspiration i
think you are thank you do you have any
assistance
thanks
yeah but do you have any aspiration to
do anything scripted
have you been asked to do anything
scripting no movie aspiration is like
when you run a long time and you your
body gets moist no it's perspiration oh
forget what i said
um no i don't no i'm not good at acting
like straight up i'm horrible acting i
would love to like write something and
like make like a film maybe one day but
i can't act anything
how do you film ideas talk to me yeah
yeah okay well i know who to go to now i
was into acting no he just wants you to
talk to him he can't do anything about
it i can't help you but no he just wants
to be talked to he doesn't get out a lot
that's why he's asking who you are but
since you're on camera a lot what's your
resting face look like i can give you
some oh mine's so bad let's let's see
here's mine
yeah that's a lot better than mine
that's your resting face it looks like a
lot of effort for resting
that's your business i reckon you'd be
great in a sort of entourage why would
you come up with the idea of doing a
break
oh you're talking to let them talk go
ahead yeah wouldn't you be good in a
sort of entourage-ish little dicky type
show i did acting though the one thing i
did was uh do you do you know those
commercials that play on the radio
that's like does your son or daughter
want to be a nickelodeon star have you
ever heard those commercials i don't
listen to radio well
you listen to radio
i mean i used to yeah yeah b96.3 swoon
so that would play like in the suburbs
of chicago it's where i'm from and my
mom and dad heard it and i like i was
obsessed with like disney channel i
really wanted to act i wanted to get
into entertainment one way or another
and so we went to this audition and i
they made me go through a bunch of
scenes with this person
um and then i got a call like four days
later and they were like your son he got
the role and my mom was [ __ ]
so excited she was screaming through the
entire house um but then when we got
there to like do our second audition it
was a scam and they like they ask you
that they they asked for like thirty
thousand dollars for like the full
course
and then maybe we'll put you in front of
like real casting directors and stuff
like that did you pay it of course it
was like that's right
what was it robert j powers or something
remember there was like a modeling thing
in all the malls and i'd always oh it's
the same yeah same thing yeah yeah and
my mom so that's one of the perfect
people to fall for something like that
so that's what dissolution you want to
do you want to be like a you could be
like an action star
good buddy it would be fun i would do it
i don't turn opportunities down that
much anymore because how else do you get
the opportunity to grow if you don't
take and make choices that scare the
[ __ ] out of you well and the example the
perfect example is you showed up here
today
just by doing that i get to live in
america now i get to travel the world
and get paid to have adventures and work
with cool people like dave and come on
podcast with you guys
that wouldn't have happened if i just
sort of got upset after the shark attack
and sat around in my ass
you got it yay oh sorry and lou and lou
yeah okay
you don't think too much you just say
yes to opportunities that come your way
nicely yeah yeah
yeah have you ever have you ever put a
shrimp on david's a thinker yeah i know
that david i know that about you david
what do you mean you think you worry
well i was just i was just actually
thinking to myself who is lou and how
did he get
you know what's weird you are sharing
that thought with the entire audience
[Music]
you